well it's been more than a year since a
former Georgia prosecutor was indicted
and now she finally has a date for an
arraignment hearing Jackie Johnson was
the district attorney for Brunswick an
area in South Georgia she's charged with
two felonies accused of hindering a
police investigation into the killing of
Ahmad Arbury Gregory McMichael his son
Travis and neighbor William Roddy Brian
chased Arbury a black man while he was
jogging through a neighborhood they
believed that he may have stolen items
from a home under construction and when
Travis McMichael confronted Arbury with
a gun the two struggled over it before
arbory was shot three times the three
white men said that they were trying to
make a citizen's arrest but they were
ultimately convicted at trial of murder
a judge from a nearby County was
assigned Johnson's case because all the
judges in the county where arbory was
killed recused themselves Brian you've
been following this I mean more than a
year between being charged and getting
an Raymond hearing that seems very
unusual to me Jesse it's extremely
unusual for post-indictment arraignment
usually these happen weeks after
indictment not 14 months but George will
finally see former Brunswick judicial
circuit district attorney Jackie Johnson
faced two felony charges for allegedly
hindering the prosecution of the now
convicted murderers of Ahmad Arbury we
were there Jesse if you remember from
that trial long crime brought these
brought these proceedings for gavel to
gavel coverage of the death of Ahmad
Arbury with interviews with Wanda Cooper
Jones Ahmad aubry's mother Lee Merritt
and from the defense attorneys in the
case now according to the Attorney
General's office handling Johnson's case
this case almost never happened because
Johnson allegedly told police not to
arrest Travis or Gregory McMichael after
the shooting death of Ahmad Arbury
Gregory McMichael the father worked for
Johnson's office as an investigator
Johnson was indicted September 2nd of
2021 and has been out on bond since her
arraignment isn't until December 29th
where she will be read her charges and
likely plead not guilty also on top of
that emotion will also be reviewed dude
as Johnson's attorneys say quote not a
scintilla of evidence unquote shows
Johnson told two Glenn County officers
not to arrest the McMichaels now Johnson
also faces a violation of office charge
I think this is a difficult one as well
because this is for allegedly not
treating Aubrey's family Fairly and with
dignity that she showed favor to her
former employee Greg McMichael and
failed to tell the aeg's office that she
consulted district attorney Barnell
about the case before recommending it to
him it was there that the trial we were
there for the trial openings closing
there's no love lost between Brunswick
County and Glenn County for Jackie
Johnson and with the state and federal
convictions McMichaels I think this is
going to be a difficult case for Johnson
yeah Terry so Brian mentioned Ahmad
aubry's mother Wanda Cooper Jones and
she fought long and hard for this case
to move forward at the end of the day
what can be done more to ensure that
this type of interference doesn't happen
again in a different case well let's
hope it doesn't happen again but what
she she did was she stayed Vigilant she
made sure she stayed on top of this case
and one of the things that you have to
do because the criminal justice system
is difficult enough but then when it's
stacked against you you have to have
someone by your side helping you and she
had attorneys by her side who made sure
they stayed on top of what was happening
in this case and they found out what was
going on and they were the ones who
brought it to the attention of the
authorities and basically if you want to
get to the source of this type of
unethical Behavior you have to train
lawyers what they're supposed to do and
not to do yeah she's in a lot of hot
water and by the way the three men who
chased down mod arbory and filmed his
death they were found guilty on all
counts including murder in Georgia as
well as counts in their Federal hate
crimes trial now prosecutors said that
the men chased arbory because he was
black Greg and Travis McMichael both
received a life sentence on the state
charges as well as another life sentence
for the federal charges as for William
Roddy Bryant he was was given life in
prison with the possibility of parole in
30 years plus another 35 years for the
hate crime charges